Sì ti aspetta un momento Mi è cresciuta
la cresta Guardate
rutta greca
dove siamo siamo a scuola che dice
l'insegnante
bla bla bla bla bla
Ehi Anita eh Questa classe è così noiosa
dice il nostro compagno di classe
perché non suoni la campanella
così possiamo scappare dalla scuola ok
Cosa faccio sono la campanella così non
la tapparella
abbiamo fatto la fusione da evitare
siamo così in due allora questa è una
nuovissima Escape Room in cui dobbiamo
scappare dalla nuova scuola Io adoro le
Escape proprio in cui dobbiamo scappare
dalla scuola o dalla prigione vediamo
abbiamo l'uniforme il nostro uniforme
vascolare io ho sempre un pilota di
linea un pilota di aerei uh
Qua c'è uno studente che sta dormendo È
non gliene frega proprio niente che
qualcosa del genere Oh sveglia Oh non
credo che si sveglierà qua c'è un'altra
giocatrice e qua Questo studente dice
siamo stati in questa classe per 6 ore
direi che il momento di andare via
Allora via via
e poi quest'altro studente invece è
quello che c'ha parlato prima Cioè ha
detto di suonare la campanella Ok è
arrabbiatissimo Qua c'è l'insegnante che
sta parlando da solo ma non si sente
nessun suono vuole parlare Che cosa c'è
scritto qui sulla lavagna non capisco
cos'è di matematica e quindi che non
capisco proprio poi Qua c'è un libro con
scritto cheeseburger eh
Non lo so Ci sono dei libri strani Anche
qui c'è un libro sulla cattedra e dice
la storia della paperella epica eh Che
cos'è la paperella epica credo che sia
un po' strana questa scuola insegna cose
strane quindi che cosa facciamo Secondo
voi andiamo a suonare il campanello come
ci ha detto questo studente Oppure
facciamo Boh bravi buoni alunni e ci
sediamo eh aspettiamo la lezione sto
guardando le farfalle dalla finestra
Guarda farfalle Sì ci sono delle
farfalle colorate arancioni bianche
Gialle blu cioè che bellezza quello
bellissimo
e poi ci sono delle macchine che passano
Chissà se riusciremo a scappare arrivare
lì Ma voi lasciate un mi piace il mi
piace sotto questa Escape Room Vi
porterà fortuna a scuola quindi cliccate
mi piace qua sotto e io vado a suonare
la campanellina così
eccola la campanella che facciamo
suoniamo
vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
che è successo non ha funzionato
si è aperta la porta aiuto via cambiamo
prima che ci prima che se ne accorgano
Oh fratello allora innanzitutto ci
abbiamo l'acqua in bottiglia dal da
questo distributore e poi e poi e poi
Qua c'è acqua che fa tutte le parti vedi
bisogna saltare sopra è successo
qualcosa qua si è rotto qualche qualcosa
qua sono rotti Beh insomma noi dobbiamo
sbrigarci perché se Scoprono che abbiamo
premuto noi il campanello d'allarme ci
bocceranno sicuramente ci sospenderanno
Ma noi andiamo avanti ma il nostro
obiettivo è finire No vabbè Leggi il
nome di questa
bevanda
rutta Grinch
ah ah Probabilmente questo momento ti fa
ruttare ah ah abbiamo bisogno di trovare
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere che cosa
diceva di trovare un posto dove
nasconderci correre rapidamente corri
rapidamente aspettami Ti sei incastrato
in fretta presto non riesco a salire qui
perché ora ti prendere il preside della
scuola e ti sospende ah ah aspetta il
labirinto qui eh Che cosa è successo
niente perché se vai nella parte
sbagliata del labirinto ti sfracella ho
visto che sei stato macinata Ah pure io
Ah ah ah Non mi ricordo più dove sono
andata forse qua a destra No vabbè non
ci credo sono andata dalla stessa parte
una volta frullata allora a destra
vediamo
rimarrai là dietro Ciao ciao
a destra Vediamo se mi frulla anche qua
no no no è vero Ok Google Translate come
sempre tradotto male forse voleva dire
siamo nei sotterranei Stai attento alla
lava Beh perché ogni scuola ha dei
sotterranei con la lavagna
è normalissimo
qui con delle delle costole Io non lo so
che cos'è sono gli studenti che hanno
provato a scappare prima non ce l'hanno
fatta Poverino
Guarda quant'è grande il teschio un po'
strano Sì vabbè l'importante è che io
super Vitale piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano
Ciao ciao
Oh eh Ma che succede Chi vincerà Secondo
voi Anita Vitale Ultimamente sta
vincendo sempre io Non puoi passare di
là Beh cosa hai fatto Ciao
molto divertente per ora Questo
skateboard Chissà se dovremo affrontare
il preside o l'insegnante alla fine mmm
Allora
C'è mancato poco che misura c'è Wow
uh uh bellissimo Ciao Anita Sono in
vantaggio Ciao ciao
le storie invece del pavimento è Lava il
pavimento è Slime Ora ti attivo
verde fluo Oh sto perdendo l'equilibrio
che ho superato adesso Certo che è
proprio strana questa scuola eh eh eh
infatti
Ciao Ma perché vanno così lenti i
personaggi di Roblox
Attenzione qui c'è un buco
bene Benvenuto Vitale è il momento della
classe di ginnastica Ah ah ah bello
ho pulito il pavimento della palestra
per cui sicuri di non cadere eh
assicuratevi di non cadere Ok Quindi il
pavimento è scivoloso figo ma cosa
dicono questi due studenti Oh non questo
di nuovo sopravvivendo a poco la
settimana
questo
ok Sarebbe meglio se li lasciassero in
inglese almeno si capirebbe di più Vabbè
comunque Insomma sono disperati questi
studenti
sì che dice questo è troppo duro
rinuncio Voglio andare a casa Ah questo
va bene dai Ah quindi voleva dire È
troppo difficile Voglio andare a casa
Dai però per il momento sembra Ok Sembra
molto facile bello questo parkour in
palestra quindi ci sarà un parkour in
ogni area della scuola bellissimo Oh
guarda Rita Guarda dove sono ciao ciao
ciao
sbrigati sbrigati
in quest'ora di educazione fisica
prenderò io il voto più alto Non lo so
eh visto che io sono avanti e sono super
Atletico
guarda– Oh che è successo oh non è
ancora finito dybala
ma mi sa che dobbiamo giocare a calcio
adesso non è ancora finita dobbiamo
passare tutti
nel calcio credo sia rugby ha detto
calcio eh Il tuo lavoro è di passare
tutti gli studenti ok Siamo fuori qui in
effetti non sembra a calcio
ah ah ah ah che paura Mi hanno ferma non
mi fanno passare Ah sono rimasti lì
Fermi Ciao
praticamente stavano facendo un
placcaggio il rugby No Ah e poi niente
andiamo avanti
Ciao Ce l'abbiamo fatta adesso
è stato facile Pensavo fosse più
difficile Io non ho mai capito come
funziona il rugby cioè lo vedono i film
ma non capisco mai cioè devono correre
da un lato poi da un'altra parte
praticamente si devono passare la palla
però alle volte sì sì si truccano tra
loro baseball no regà quello con la
palla ovale tieni così corri corri
No è quello con la moto da baseball è
baseball ovviamente ragazzi e voi invece
li conoscete questi Sport li avete mai
provati anzi scriveteci che sport fate
nei commenti che bello esplorare la
scuola qua allora gli unici studenti
Sopravvissuti e ho paura che qui ci
siano delle trappole giganti trappole
qua Ma sembra facile per il momento
no amore mio ah ah mi sono stressato
anch'io la prima volta tra l'altro
ragazzi di Vitale li avete Allora qua è
più difficile bisogna fare piano Sì sì
sei stato di nuovo Argelato ho
cancellato Sì Vitale
Ok Riprovo questa volta non ci credo
sempre lo stesso punto mi sfracello E
questa volta cambio passo di qua ho
cambiato strada Ok cosa dice abbiamo
bisogno di entrare in una classe scegli
la porta corretta secondo la seconda
questa quindi non scegliere la porta
sbagliata
che era il professore non ho fatto il
tempo a vederlo proviamola quella di sì
sì
vediamo qui Sì ho trovato quella giusta
Anita ho trovato quella giusta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
Vai è questa è questa Sei sicuro Sì sì
Vai vai No era questo Ehi ti stavo
facendo uno scherzo devo fare ancora in
quella sbagliata
Oggi andremo in un viaggio di campo Eh
in campo per un'altra dimensione cosa
L'unica cosa che devo fare mischiare
queste cose insieme sono le lezioni di
chimica
professore ho paura che sta sbagliato
qualche cosa finirà molto male c'è un
portale si sta aprendo il portale un
portale Wow puoi andare uno alla volta
ok Oh my god dice facciamo di un'altra
dimensione
e quest'altro studente dice Io ieri
tanto andare in un viaggio di campo
un viaggio di campo Ehi posso rubarti
qualche pozione voglio provarvi qualcuno
ok Vai prima tu così vediamo se ti
sfracelli terra di candela è scomparso
cos'è la terra di candela eh qualche
pianeta strano con gli alieni dentro
Hahaha siamo stati mangiati da qualcuno
va bene No siamo tipo nel paese dei
balocchi
mangia si mangia oggi si mangia Ok
allora perfetto per Vitale perché ci
sono tanti dolcini giganti la torta al
cioccolato con la ciliegia sopra una
fragola un gelato gigante
Cioè forse perché sei passato prima tu e
quindi il portale ha fatto tipo Tipo
Harry Potter
[Applauso]
troppo carini e quindi sotto è fatto
tutto di cioccolato
a quanto pare sì purtroppo si sarebbe
stato bello nuotare nel cioccolato per
quello che cos'è tipo una fontana di
cioccolato non la vedo c'è un cookie
gigantesca Oh dai scendi giù la strada
Allora io dico verde non è verde
blu gigante Wow bellissimo finora queste
Escape Room ha un sacco di luoghi
diversi un sacco di round diverso
caramelle
Purtroppo sì Vediamo adesso no siamo
tornati a scuola o no Benvenuto Vitale
hai pensato di aver fatto livello
ho fatto livello
ehm
Resterai detenzionato per un tempo molto
lungo ma soprattutto ho intenzione
Ah ok Siamo in punizione ma siamo
ritornati in classe aspetta ci ha messo
in punizione vediamo cosa dicono gli
altri elementi
[Musica]
per entrare Ah ok Forse dobbiamo
scappare dal vento là sopra Vedi
Come si dice i Condotti d'aria vedi che
qui c'è la porta con i laser Sì
sicuramente non possiamo entrare
possiamo provare ma
ti sei iscritta coi laser è un momento
ho pensato che ero riuscita a scappare
No io stavo vedendo che qui Vedi ci sono
tutti i cavi magari coi cavi possiamo
fare qualcosa attivarlo non c'è niente
da premere andiamo a vedere se troviamo
qualcosa qui allora è un pulsante questa
Luna dice Eh Che cosa guardi che è
simpatica sì che aspetta un momento mi è
piaciuto la cresta Guardate ah ah ho
parlato con quella luna con la cresta
Hahaha
Non dovevo parlargli Certo che ehm Però
è carina sembra tipo un unicorno adesso
sembra la cresta del cavallo
Uh le porte sono a prova di laser forse
quello vento può liberarsi dai parla in
italiano Eh
sì quindi abbiamo avuto Quest'anno no
svegliare Ehi Aspetta vai a prendere
anche tu la cre andiamo a vedere come
tirarlo quella viola vediamo Oh Dammi la
cresta Dammi la cresta ho detto non me
la dà No forse era quest'altro studente
Allora era questo Dammi la tua cresta
Forse ho capito Devi sfracellarti qua
apposta in questa porta e poi ti
crescerà la cresta vediamo
sono riuscito a passare il gelato
Vediamo
se ora avrà la cresta Ma no eh Ma come è
possibile
Boh non lo so come è fatta comparirmi la
classe però mi piace però la lascerò Ok
allora
siamo riusciti a passare Ok Ora proviamo
la gente se n'è andata Non ti trovo Ah
eccoti Eh io vado di qua Ok Io ti seguo
tutti
no no no non ho più like credo di aver
preso la strada sbagliata visto che sono
stato macinato da quella ventola
io non ho neanche detto Vediamo se me la
Rida
troppo carini ora siamo pronti per
andare alla cresta ci porterà fortuna
Forse allora da dove si doveva andare da
questa parte mi sa
Sì sì sì sì forza ho trovato la via
d'uscita ciao ciao ciao ciao
cosa ho trovato qui
soprattutto se la parte no questo non è
la parte giusto Guardate una cosa
sbrilluccicante dove Dai scendi giù da
qua penso non lo so no
dall'altra parte devi andare vai
sinistra Brava ok
Non lo so che cos'è questa forse è una
chiave magnetica
però abbiamo aperto la porta Siamo
troppo forti Allora adesso dobbiamo
tornare indietro forse credo che
dobbiamo andare da qui vediamo vediamo
tornare indietro Attento a non cadere
non lo avrete sbagliata vediamo sì ok
Abbiamo perso la porta
che Siamo bravissimi con questa cresta
siamo diventati ancora più bravi
cosa è successo
attivazione laser
maestri sono cattivi Non possiamo
permettere dirle
Ok va bene Devi prendere
Ehi io ce l'ho fatta stasera puoi
farcela Anche tu visto che non facciano
i miei amici questo qui con non so se le
vediamo dai dai dai
non so neanche io che cosa ho detto Ecco
i resti di Vitale c'era praticamente qui
ma il professore o quello l'ha detto la
sicurezza che si sta guardando con un
pulsante rosso in mano e con un pulsante
verde per toglierli indietro per non lo
so prendere il pulsante ma non si può
vedere la porta non ci fa entrare Cioè
siamo finiti Wow che dice
guarda
Guarda il pregavamo
[Applauso]
E vabbè io non ti aspetto io vado eh
sono qui ancora sfracellato non mi fa
più rinascere Cioè quindi questo era il
parco
[Musica]
Three Days later Ok ragazzi Eccoci di
nuovo qua si era disconnessa internet
abbiamo dovuto rifare tutto da capo
Carmen
lava come adesso perché sono lì dentro
però io sono riuscita a prendere la
crema
colorata Però se mi sfracello scomparirà
quindi proviamo lo sfracellarci il tempo
Sarebbe bello riuscire a prendere il
badge con la crema sarà molto difficile
molto difficile soprattutto questa parte
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano Quindi ora siamo nel parco
giochi della scuola che però è stato
sommerso dalla Certo che questa altalene
sono un po' giganti ci sono riuscito non
ce la puoi fare
No voglio vedere anch'io Vediamo
passare ma è una scorciatoia Allora
aiuto Fateci passare
dalla macchina non mi ha schiacciato ci
sono passato sopra Eh non lo so che è
successo
No non mi fa passare l'escape Room
altrimenti poi quindi devi rifare tutta
nel pavimento e lava eh
Però per poco non mi schiaccia una
macchina ma non mi ha schiacciato
Sì sto arrivando io la mia cresta È
troppo bella questa Escape Room la
scuola è gigante Allora qui forse si
sono rotti i distributori perché c'è
l'acqua dappertutto
sono in testa eh no no Ah ah ah C'è
mancato poco mi stavo per sprecare
A proposito di capelli è di fretta Avete
visto il video in cui scappiamo dal
barbiere robot che taglia i capelli e
super divertente dopo questo video vi
lascio la casellina Alla fine cliccatela
andate a vederlo e poi mi fate sapere
che voto date a quelle Escape Room da 1
a 10 ma ora è tempo di prendere un rutto
dai proviamo brutto grip faceva i rutti
Chissà che sapore Haha allora che cosa
dice la classe di adart che dice in
cerca di abitare messiah
Ok va bene ragazzi sta diventando sempre
peggio Questo è Google Translate
quindi siamo nella lezione razzistica
d'arte Infatti ci sono le matite le
penne i pastelli e le tempere Che bello
Adoro il fatto che ci sia un'area
diversa per ogni classe E poi ogni tanto
c'è qualcosa di antipatico
Oh Dio ti buttati nella lava incendiati
ma perché
e poi
uno di questi armadietti a un percorso
segreto cerchiamo
dobbiamo cercare in queste armadietti
segreti vediamo chi trova prima il
percorso 3
entrarono a Trento tutti e trentatré
trollando
Ah ah ah ah Ehi sei un campione mi hai
seguito e allora che vuoi oh quello non
è passato dai ti sei sprecata no Ok
andiamo Uhm quanto siamo scesi in basso
qui attento perché qua
c'è tipo il vento la ventola che ti
spinge dall'altra parte mi ha spinto giù
eh devi continuare a camminare
velocissimo perché altrimenti scivoli
giù si può anche saltare Forse è meglio
saltare sì eh Se ci riesci proprio ma
quando uno salta dovrebbe essere peggio
però questo caso ha funzionato uhm uhm
Wow sono diventati entrambi io che sono
il mio punto c'è un nuovo panino
Guarda come dobbiamo andare a nuotare e
dammi il tuo salvagente Però non ho
capito dove dobbiamo andare senza
salvagente Allora abbiamo preso tipo Eh
ma ti sei già buttato Uno due tre Wow
Dai dai dai
Dobbiamo andare di qua eh fighissimo
così
manca poco stiamo proprio nei
sotterranei della scuola Ok adesso
dobbiamo risalire su salta salta wow wow
c'è qualcuno qui andiamo a vedere cosa
c'è dentro questo
non riesco a rimanere Aspetta non dice
niente questo Eh no sta solo nuotando Oh
aspetta devo fare i tuffi là sopra è
bellissima
Sì cosa siamo i tuffi facciamo il tuffo
alto Allora io ti guardo ok Aspetta non
so come salire
però no
ah ah Che figo io vado in quello più
alto Uh Fa paura da quassù uh uh è
morbido Guardate sono tantissimo Wow
pronti 3 2 ah ah
oh è rimbalzato Eh perché ho saltato
Vabbè dai Dobbiamo completare noi Ciao
io vado avanti tu continua a fare i
tuffi No ehm c'è qualcosa che non quadra
qui e queste sono le docce Ma le hanno
lasciate aperte hanno allagato tutto no
Ehi sono rimasta incastrato devi saltare
stiamo affondando tipo che succede sono
tipo sabbia mobile stiamo scivolando ok
che bello esplorare tutta la scuola
Forse bisogna spostare questo Boh non lo
so oppure si va di qua Mmm mi sa che
bisogna entrare nel bagno dei maschi a
me non fa entrare nel bagno delle
femmine volevo dire che dobbiamo lavare
Eh ho visto tutta la scuola da fuori per
un momento eh sì sappiamo che non è
sempre
ma perché continua a sfracellarlo non
capisco No no non mi dire che siamo
nelle fogne adesso ma non ci ha mangiato
nessuno ancora no vabbè ok
Eccomi qua secondo te che cos'è questa
aria sembrano le fogne forse no Magari
solo potrebbe anche tu che ci fa
scappare Ecco
torniamo indietro quale strada dobbiamo
prendere allora dall'altra parte
Beatrice È solo questa credo E aspetta
c'è una strada qua ecco la via d'uscita
Come faccio a trovarla
trovato
io ti ho già superato sopra questi tubi
Eh
ho preso preso
aspettato
Eccolo qui
siamo nelle fogne mamma mia meno male
non si sente l'odore qua
sono tipo radioattive queste cose
Un po' difficile insomma l'ho capito
l'ho capito ma non te lo dico
non ho capito anch'io ho bisogno di
andare qua No tu sei da un'altra parte
Guarda ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao È
super avanti perché ho preso la strada
sbagliata
Oh aspetta ho sbagliato Anch'io sono
riuscita ad uscire No non mi dire che
c'è il Belgio Congratulazioni sì
cosa faccio prima di me sì sono uscito
fuori dalla scuola dai di' poco di poco
Eccoti Bravi Bravissimi
Eh sono riuscita a scappare hai fuorito
la scuola Dai vieni qui sull'altalena
giochiamo solo altalena ah ah dov'è
Dov'è dov'è lo sci
volo era una trappola tipo ti ha sparato
tipo
fuori dalla scuola ma insomma Ehi dove
sono finita voglio provarlo anch'io lo
scivolo Bravo sono rimasta qua nel metà
verso tipo teletrasportato da qualche
parte che non so dove Eh
sono nel tetto mi sa che siamo siamo
nello stesso posto sì
no dove sei tu stai volando
Anita sono scoperte Ciao Ok Vabbè c'è
qualcosa che non ha funzionato Comunque
l'importante è che ho preso il badge era
bellissimo questo Escape Room e gli do
un voto 9 e tu un bel 10 perché mi è
divertito Anzi 9 e mezzo perché a un
certo punto Si è interrotto tutto e
quindi son dovuto ritornare indietro
pazienza porca madonna gli date
scrivetelo nei commenti ora vi lasciamo
Qua quattro roselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quello che preferite eh Buona visione
Ciao